>>> WE DON'T OFTEN EQUATE ;
a
PHILOSOPHERS WITH BRAVERY, BUT
BERNARD HENRI LEVY BREAKS THE
MOLD.
HE'S TRAVELED TO MANY OF THE
FRONT LINE LOKES WE'VE HEARD ;
a
ABOUT THT NEWS.
PLACES LIKE KHERSON, ODESA AND ;
a
BAKHMUT
HE WENT TO BEAR WITNESS AND
BROUGHT A FILM CREW TO DOCUMENT;
a
WHAT HE SAW.
THE RESULT IS AN IMPRESSIVE NEW
DOCUMENTARY CALLED SLAVA
UKRAINE, MEANING GLORY TO
UKRAINE.
IT IS OUT NOW IN SELECT THEATER;
a
>> THANK YOU.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THE ;
a
ISSUE OF BRAVERY.
IT IS STRUCK ME AS SOMETIMES ;
a
WE THINK ABOUT SMARTS AND
INTELLIGENCE AND BUT IF YOU ;
a
THINK OF GREAT LEADERSHIP, LIKE
WITH ZELENSKYY, BRAVERY, COURAGE
IS ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
THINGS.
DO YOU THINK THAT IS TRAINED?
DO YOU THINK IT IS IN-BORN?
>> IT IS ONE OF THE MOST ;
a
IMPORTANT AND ONE OF THE MOST ;
FORGOTTEN.
WE WERE SO SURPRISED WHEN
ZELENSKYY DECIDED TO STAY.;
a
WHOLE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE STOOD AT;
HIS SIDE.
IT WAS ABSOLUTELY UNEXPECTED.;
a
NONE OF US THOUGHT THAT.;
NEVERTHELESS, IT HAPPENED.
WE HAVE BRAVE CITIZENSHIP LIKE
IN THE BEGINNING OF AMERICA, ;
a
GREECE, LIKE IN THE FRENCH ;
REVOLUTION.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED MANY ;
a
UKRAINE.
AND THIS IS ONE OF THE GREAT
EVENTS WHICH WE SAW.
>> WHEN YOU WENT ON THE FRONT ;
a
SOLDIERS, THEY'RE UP AGAINST AR;
RUSSIAS ARE HAMMERING AND
THEY'RE DOING THINGS THAT ARE ;
a
ARE REALLY WE HAVEN'T SEEN SINCE
WORLD WAR II, DESTROYING WHOLE ;
a
CITIES, BOMBING THE SEWAGE ;
PLANTS AND THE WATER FACILITIES;
a
AN THE HOSPITALS.
ARE THEY LOSING THEIR NERVE?
ARE THEY LOSING THEIR COURAGE?
>> I NEVER SAW THAT.
MAYBE IT HAPPENS.
BUT I NEVER SAW THAT.
I WAS IN A LOT OF HOT PLACES AN;
a
FAKE ONE, GOING TO THE ENEMY.;
BUT THE MASTER OF BRAVERY ;
a
.
L
OF THE PEOPLE UNDER SHELTER,
GOING TO FETCH THEM UNDER FIRE.
THIS I SAW MANY TIMES AND THIS ;
a
COMMENTARY IN MANY SCENES.
>> YOU KNOW THAT PEOPLE LOOK AT;
a
THE STRATEGIC SITUATION FROM
AFAR AND THEY SAY, LOOK, THE ;
a
THE END OF THE DAY, THE RUSSIANS
ARE HAVE DUG IN, IN CRIMEA AND ;
a
SO THERE WILL HAVE TO BE SOME ;
NEGOTIATION, THERE WILL HAVE TO;
a
BE IN SETTLEMENT.
WHAT DO YOU SEE?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
NUMBER ONE, IF THERE IS A
COMPROMISE, IT WOULD BE A
DISASTER FOR ALL OF US.
WHEN YOU DO COMPROMISE WITH ;
a
HIS ENEMY, AND THAT HE DECLARED;
TOTAL WAR AGAINST THE WHOLE ;
a
.
A COMPROMISE WITH PUTIN IS FOR
ALL OF US A BAD THING, NUMBER
ONE.
NUMBER TWO, I DON'T THINK IT ;
a
.
WHAT I OBSERVED ON THE GROUND ;
a
DURING THESE SIX MONTHS OF ;
UKRAINIANS DECIDED WITH THEIR
WISE BRAVERY TO LAUNCH AN ;
a
.
AND SOMETIMES, VERY OFTEN, THE ;
a
.
SO WHEN THEY WILL DECIDE THAT
THEY ARE STRONG ENOUGH, EQUIPPED
ENOUGH TO GO TO DONETSK, TO GO ;
a
TO CRIMEA, THEY WILL.
AND YOU WILL BE SURPRISED HOW
LITTLE THE RUSSIANS WILL RESIST.
NUMBER THREE, THE ONLY THING ;
a
THAT IS MISSING AND WHICH WE ;
STRONGLY, QUICKLY, AND NOT IN
THE INCREMENTAL WAY WHICH IS TH;
a
IF WE GIVE WHAT THEY NEED, ;
.
>> YOU ARE A BIG SUPPORTER OF ;
a
EMMANUEL MACRON IN FRANCE.
ON THIS ISSUE, DO YOU THINK
MACRON IS SEARCHING FOR A ;
a
COMPROMISE, A SOLUTION?
HE STILL TALKS TO PUTIN.;
a
T
>> I THINK SO.
I -- I THINK THAT MACRON NEVER ;
a
.
HE SPOKE WITH HIM AT THE
BEGINNING, NOT TO SUCH A ;
a
COMPROMISE, TO APPEAL TO WHAT H;
.
a
NOT TO MAKE A COMPROMISE.
THERE IS ONE POIN ON WHICH ;
a
MACRON NEVER CHANGED.
PUTIN AND RUSSIA HAS TO BE
DEFEATED.
UKRAINE HAS TO GET THE VICTORY.
AND THE VICTORY MEANS WHAT THEY
WILL SAY, THEY ALWAYS SAID THAT
AND I HAD THE PRIVILEGE, BY THE
WAY, TO BE ASKED BY MACRON TO BE
THERE IN HIS LAST MAN-TO-MAN ;
a
MEETING WITH ZELENSKYY IN PARIS;
.
I WAS IF THE ROOM WITH ANDRE AN;
a
I SAW THE POSITION OF MACRON WA;
VERY CLEAR.
THE VICTORY HAS TO BE YOURS,
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY.
AND WHAT VICTORY MEANS IS FOR
YOU TO DECIDE, NOT US.
NOT DIPLOMATS, THOUGHT
AMERICANS, FRANCE, NOT EUROPE.;
a